Mì vậy thống người, chứ chình lương thức tế giới với kép app cho biến,
Trung bình mỗi ngày đang có khoảng 5,5 so many tận lương thức lực truyền vào giải gaza.
Cái tự khi thaw thận lượng bản dưới sợi anh bà được lượng hả mắt có hiểu lực.
Tuy nhiên lượng hàng ngày bởi cách xả mất cần thiết để đáp ở vụ gầu của hơn 2 triệu người dân trong vùng kia xưa.
Nguyên phần mỗi người kép app app app ở biệt app, để phà nhìn định lượng hương bán đảm ơn giá một khoảng thời gian quyết giá cho hạt động kiu trở.
Sông việc tiếp cận và gặp nhiều trở ngại, giòn hạt tận hương hại nắng và các cửa khẩu phía bắt giải gaza tiếp tục bị đống.
Bà cho biến thành phủ gaza nơi tình trạm thiếu lượng thực nhìn phọng nhất và trưa thể được tiếp nhận biệt chợ.
Hện mới còn 5 bài xe cài được phép và khu vực phía năm và chúng tông dài đất.
Chông khi một tiêu cần đặt là tảm ơn để 1 xam xe một ngày.
Phó tổng thư ký để hấp quốc phụ trên nhìn đạo ông tôn flat chờ cảnh bảo.
Nạn đối đã sớt hiện tại nhiều khu vực nhấn mạnh chữ khi hăng nghìn sẽ kiu trở được phép bảo giải gaza mức tôn.
Tình hình nhìn đạo mới có thể được cả tiện.
Chông một giữ liên quan, Israel đã đoổi ý mở lại cửa khẩu ra phá phía năm.
Vào ngày 12 thống mời giới sự giảm xác của liên mình châu Âu và sự hiện diện của chính quyền Palestine.
Kỳ Kỳ này sẽ châu phép bệnh nhân người bị thương và giúp khách qua lại 2 chiều.
Đây là một bước đi thành chốt nhằm nối lãi horde động vật chuyển hàng kiu trở.
Sau khi chào viết tưởng cảnh báo sẽ tiếp tục đón cụ hộ ra phá,
nếu lựa hảm ắt khung bản giáo đủ tọn độ 2 mệt tạm thi thể còn tiền thiệt mạc.